Olivier python il est avocat aux
États-Unis dans le district de
Washington c'est un avocat français bien
sûr bonjour mes Python
bonjour alors il y a beaucoup
d'informations qui ont été rendues
publiques récemment dans la dernière
heure notamment les accusations l'exposé
des faits aussi et sur les accusations
des 34 chefs on parle de 34
falsifications de registre d'entreprise
en anglais c'est falshine business
return de quoi est-ce qu'on parle ici
bah écoutez en fait ce qui a expliqué
Alvin braque donc le procureur du comté
de de New York de Manhattan c'est qu'en
fait Donald Trump c'était en fait il a
dit deux choses la première il a dit
Donald Trump s'est rendu coupable de
falsification de dissimulation
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit de
documents de registre commerciaux comme
on dit de business wikoords de l'État de
New York et ça c'était la partie sur
laquelle on l'attendait on attendait
alvid brag et donc on a pas été surpris
c'est effectivement après le déroulé des
34 chefs d'accusation qui découlent
toujours de cette même volonté de
falsifier les registres commerciaux de
l'État de New York pourquoi faire pour
dissimuler alors deux choses une qui
était attendue c'est effectivement le
paiement
de 130 000 dollars pour
acheter le silence de de stormy Daniels
ça on le savait mais comme l'a rappelé
votre votre collègue fort justement il y
avait en plus qui a été annoncé le fait
d'avoir payé 30 000 dollars pour cacher
dissimuler le fait que Donald Trump est
mis une femme enceinte et qu'il est donc
un enfant illégitime donc ça c'est la
partie attendue c'est la partie je
dirais la plus classique ce qui en
revanche les beaucoup moins c'est la
justification pourquoi cette
dissimulation et ce qu'explique le
procureur c'est que Donald Trump a voulu
dissimuler ces informations dans le but
de modifier changer la perception du
corps électoral pour les élections
présidents l'élection les élections il y
en a eu 50 les élections présidentielles
de 2016 et là c'est quand même beaucoup
plus léger ce sera beaucoup plus
difficile de convaincre effectivement le
jury qu'il y avait cette intention en
tout cas que si cette intention était là
elle a véritablement porté son but
est-ce qu'on peut estimer je termine
là-dessus que les 130 000 dollars de
paiement plus les 30000 dollars de
paiement ont permis de modifier le
résultat de l'élection c'est quand même
assez peu probable alors ça mettre
python ces accusations d'avoir falsifié
des documents est-ce que c'est grave
est-ce que ça pourrait entraîner des
peines importantes par exemple
oui tout à fait légitimement Alvin brag
a raison il y a enfin de son point de
vue il va falloir qu'il le prouve on
rappelle toujours que
à une personne est considérée comme
innocente tant qu'elle n'a pas été
condamné mais il va chercher à prouver
et visiblement il était très à l'aise il
avait de vrais arguments il va réussir à
prouver cette dissimulation ce que
risque Donald Trump c'est simplement
expliquer dans le fameux code article
175 du code de l'État de New York il
risque officiellement entre un an et
quatre ans de prison
reste à savoir effectivement si on en
arrivera à cela il y a un deuxième
aspect qui est important c'est le délai
on part sur un procès à compter de la
fin de l'année 2023 début de l'année
2024 donc on va avoir du temps aussi
pour voir comment les choses vont
maintenant se développer j'aimerais ça
vous entendre sur un autre aspect Donald
Trump il a fait des déclarations assez
virulentes assez critique du procureur
brag notamment du juge il a été il a dit
que que l'un était raciste que l'autre
voulait sa tête est-ce que des
conséquences légales possible à faire
des commentaires comme ça
en tout cas ça va on ne sait pas si
alors il y a deux personnes qui ont été
mises en cause il y a Alvin brag
effectivement le procureur mais il y a
également le juge qui devrait d'après ce
que disent les médias américains se
saisir du dossier maintenant c'est one
marchand et ranmotion c'est quelqu'un de
très connu puisque c'est celui qui avait
déjà investigué qui avait déjà enquêté
sur les malversations supposées de la
Trump organisations c'est celui dont
Donald Trump disait il me déteste donc
il a effectivement porté des accusations
très graves sur ces deux personnalités
est-ce que il peut risquer effectivement
une peine supplémentaire oui parce que
au bout du compte le combat on l'a bien
compris il n'est pas que judiciaire il
est aussi médiatique il est aussi
politique donc on va voir déjà ce que
donnera la conférence de presse de ce
soir en Floride de Nolan Trump on
pensait les jeux termine là-dessus que
Alvin brag avait intimé l'ordre le
fameux gag order la fameuse consigne de
silence
à Donald Trump de se taire il semblerait
que ce ne soit pas le cas donc nous
aurons beaucoup plus de détails ce soir
sur la défense dans Donald Trump sur la
manière surtout dont il va attaquer en
particulier Alvin brag parce que s'il y
avait eu ce gag order ce bâillon là sur
Donald Trump a fait l'interdiction de
commenter il n'aurait pas pu tenir cette
conférence de presse ce soir on verra
bien si la tient mais ça ça
l'empêcherait de le faire
alors il y a deux choses la première
c'est qu'il peut parler le gag horde la
consigne de silence porte sur l'affaire
proprement dite mais dans nos soins pour
très bien utiliser sa tribune pour
parler des affaires en général sans
aborder directement ce qui s'est passé
cet après-midi donc si vous voulez on va
voir comment il va le tourner en tout
cas il n'a pas parlé à New York on ne
sait pas ce qui va on ne sait pas si le
gargoudeur a effectivement été décrété
et on verra ce que Donald Trump va dire
est-ce qu'il va parler précisément de la
faire ou est-ce qu'il va essayer de se
poser en victime et prendre un petit peu
si vous voulez l'ensemble un petit peu
comme ça global et général des
poursuites qui qui s'adressent à lui et
bien c'est le suspense jusqu'à ce soir
merci infiniment Olivier python au
revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI